so
[Music]
[Music]
termina is a weird place so weird in
fact that even to this day people can
still not fully agree on what it is
exactly and why it looks the way it does
it's a world that lies parallel to
hyrule an alternate dimension only
accessible through a mysterious portal
that serves as a bridge between the two
it's clear that termina has existed for
a very long time it has its own culture
traditions deities technology and an
ancient history spanning back many ages
perhaps even as far back as that of
hyrule unlike hyrule however the people
of termina do not worship the triforce
nor the goddesses who created it instead
four giants who are described as
guardian deities govern and watch over
the land and the terminians still honor
them to this day of course over its long
history a lot of stuff happened kingdoms
and civilizations rose and fell
secretive tribes popped up only to
vanish again without a trace all leaving
behind stories relics and architecture
the most famous of which being the
elusive tribe who created the infamous
majora's mask the militaristic kingdom
of ikana and their rival faction the
garrow and whoever built the impressive
and megalithic stone tower each one of
these relics from the past has been
debated and discussed since well the
release of majora's mask in true zelda
fashion nintendo doesn't reveal much
about the history of termina leaving it
up to us the fans to craft ideas and
theories i previously covered some of
the mysteries of the kingdom of ikana
and the bordering stone tower although
both ancient in their own right it's
clear that stone tower predates the
kingdom by a significant margin its
royal family nor any of the members of
ikana seem to have known who built it in
the first place it's safe to say that if
even the people of ikana had no idea
about the origin of this imposing tower
it has to be one off if not the oldest
surviving structure in termina
additionally in the same general area we
find a secret shrine hidden behind a
waterfall this place too is almost a
complete mystery none of the members of
the old kingdom mention it so it's
unclear if they knew about its existence
and similar to stone tower we never find
out who was responsible for its
construction so in terms of a timeline
of termina civilizations we have stone
tower and possibly the secret shrine
then the ancient kingdom of ikana and
finally the current day civilizations
like clocktown romani ranch goron
village zora's domain and so on but
there's two more structures that seem to
find their origin all the way back in
the ancient past places that aren't
talked about all that much that being
the two spider houses one located in the
southern swamp and another etched into
the hills close to the beaches of great
bay a likely reason why they aren't
talked about as much as some of the
other locations i mentioned like stone
tower or the castle of ikana is because
they're not mandatory to finish the
game's story and are instead optional
side quests they are by all accounts
just a collect-a-thon inside a
self-contained area you probably aren't
supposed to think about too much but
this wouldn't be much of a zelda theory
if we didn't do exactly that but before
we get into the finer details about the
houses themselves like the architecture
history and the people responsible for
its construction we first need to cover
the most prominent aspect about the two
the spider's curse
both houses are said to be plagued by
some sort of wicked curse however the
game never elaborates on what this curse
entails exactly we don't know how and
why it exists or who placed it on these
locations all we get to see is what it
does to a person once they get afflicted
by it they are horribly mutated and
deformed turning them into a sort of
half man half spider creature we have
seen something like this before in
ocarina of time a family whose greed led
them to a similar fate however neither
ocarina or majora's mask ever explains
what someone has to do in order to get
affected by the spider's curse in the
case of the spider houses simply
wandering around inside doesn't seem to
be the cause as link himself is not
affected though i guess it could be tied
to the amount of time one spends inside
but what i find to be a more interesting
and more likely option is that it could
be triggered when someone attempts to
take or steal something from the house
and bring it with him in the swamp
spider house we do see a couple of
golden statues encrusted with jewels
some of which are missing the cursed man
at the entrance does admit that he was
looking to get rich and even his dog
refers to his master as being filled
with greed and desire the story goes
that someone gave him the mask of truth
and told him that the instructions to
get rich are inscribed somewhere inside
the house but when he went inside he
ended up getting cursed when it comes to
these secret instructions they are
indeed real but not in the form of an
artifact a treasure map or a secret
stash or anything like that instead
there's a gossip stone located in one of
the back rooms which when wearing the
mask of truth reveals the details
basically what the gossip stone does is
it explains how to cheat the dark races
being held at romani ranch by wearing
the mask you'll be able to read the
dog's mind and find out which one is the
most likely to win and it goes without
saying that exploiting a tactic like
this could indeed make someone very rich
very quickly so whoever gave the mask to
the cursed man was telling the truth
though it would have been nice if he
didn't leave out the whole you know
getting cursed part in all probability
the man was never able to find the
gossip stone or even if he did he didn't
realize he could talk to it as such he
may have helped himself to some other
riches inside taking some of the jewels
or perhaps something else of value a
mistake which cost him dearly and led to
his current state a similar thing could
have happened to the family in hyrule as
well from what we can gather they too
were digging up valuables by using the
shard of agony a magical artifact that
can track down hidden caves and grottos
they too may have one day dug up
something they shouldn't have and got
themselves cursed in the process the
oceanside spider house is said to be
cursed as well however there's no one in
need of saving which does make sense
this house has been sealed off hidden
behind a wall and clearly hasn't been
visited for a very long time no greedy
visitors means no one to steal things
and get themselves into trouble there is
a guy who shows up after clearing the
house and he wants to use it as some
sort of bomb shelter in case the moon
falls but since the curse is lifted by
that time he remains okay as okay as
someone can be right before armageddon
poor guy
the only other aspect about the curse
that's worth mentioning is that luckily
similar to ocarina of time there is a
cure by defeating all the golden
skulltula inside and collecting their
spirits the curse is lifted and anyone
affected is reverted back to normal but
this clearly does require outside help
as someone in this state would probably
not be able to lift the curse themselves
luckily for this guy link came to the
rescue now let's hope he learned from
his mistake and doesn't try anything
stupid again in the future
so that covers the curse for now next
let's dive into the actual structures
themselves in particular its
architecture and possible history
an interesting detail is that although
both locations feature a clear motif of
spider imagery on doors ceilings statues
and other ornaments their respective
building styles are vastly different
from one another the swamp spider house
isn't much of a house to begin with and
more akin to a shrine or some sort of
temple it has a big chapel-like central
chamber large golden spider statues and
more importantly no signs of a living
space no furniture beds or anything that
indicates that people actually used to
live here some rooms also seem like they
were never finished they still look like
natural caves you can still see earth
moss and ivy and one room even has a
tree in it surrounded by vegetation
screw photosynthesis i suppose the
oceanside spider house on the other hand
is more in line with what you would
expect from well a house there's a
library with an impressive amount of
books furniture like desks and chairs a
storage room filled with all sorts of
artifacts like a statue sarcophagi
gold-plated boxes what looks like a
cello and other stuff covered in drapes
or inside boxes it even has some sort of
dining or meeting room with a table in
the center surrounded by four chairs a
fancy chandelier fireplace and so on as
you can see aside from the obvious
spider themes the two locations don't
share a whole lot of similarities even
basic things like doors and pots have a
completely different design no object is
found in one or the other now does that
mean that there is no connection between
the two and that they were built by
different people maybe even in different
time periods in my opinion no i don't
think that's the case i find it highly
unlikely that there just so happen to
have been two completely different
disconnected groups of people who both
had some sort of spider obsession it
makes more sense that they were
constructed by the same hands and
approximately around the same time
however i do think that the two
locations had vastly different purposes
one seemingly being a place of worship
and the other a place where knowledge
and artifacts were being kept studies
were done and well apparently meetings
were being held the fact that the swamp
spider house looks unfinished does lead
me to believe that the ocean house was
built first or at least that its
construction was completed before the
other house so how old are these
buildings well remember how i said that
the ocean house didn't have any visitors
that's actually not entirely true while
there is no sign that anyone has
discovered it in the current day it did
have some very unlikely visitors far
back in the past that being foot
soldiers from the kingdom of ikana
talking to them reveals that they are
not the original owners of the house but
instead we're sent here to investigate
its secrets as we already discussed
previously ikana itself is already
ancient the fact that these guys don't
seem to know who this place used to
belong to or who made it and that it was
already abandoned by the time they got
here is a true testament to how old the
ocean house really is predating one of
the oldest known civilizations in
termina perhaps even dating back to the
time that stone tower was built who
knows naturally the next question would
be who were these mysterious people who
originally built the spider houses what
was their goal and what caused them to
disappear and abandon these locations
are they long dead or are they still
around somewhere well as you would
expect there is no definitive answer as
i mentioned at the beginning a lot of
terminus passed is a complete mystery
and to be honest the question of who
isn't really all that interesting to
explore simply because we almost have
nothing to work with there's plenty of
potential candidates sure the tribe who
created majira's mask the people who
constructed stone tower or the secret
shrine heck even the shika are not out
of the realm of possibility after all we
do find a gossip stone in one of the
houses alternatively it could be a group
of individuals we've never seen before
and never will for every piece of
evidence there's an equal amount of
counter evidence for example culturally
speaking none of the groups i mentioned
earlier have any relationship to spider
imagery that we know of same goes for
the modern day civilizations there's not
one piece of architecture old or new
that resembles anything we see inside
the spider houses not stone tower the
secret shrine clock town zora's domain
goron village the pirates the only thing
we know for sure is that it wasn't the
kingdom of ikana who made them and when
it comes to the tribe of majora well we
know next and nothing about them some
even make the argument that this tribe
and the people who built stone tower
might have been one in the same so
instead of shooting in the dark to see
which one of these groups was the most
likely candidate i think it's far more
interesting to leave that up in the air
and instead explore what these people
were like what it is that they were
doing and what their possible fate could
have been because at least here we have
the environment to work with which does
present some very interesting details
and possibilities
[Music]
from the looks of it there weren't that
many people involved in whatever
operation was going on at the spider
houses the ocean house is quite small
and there's only four chairs present in
the dining room or meeting room or
whatever it was used for they seem to
have been a small group who operated in
secret both houses are located
underground out of sight from the public
eye there's even a closed off room
behind the fireplace inside the ocean
house that can only be accessed if you
know the secret code the room itself is
a dome-shaped ornate chamber with a
circular rug decorated with what looks
like twin spiders a giant web motif on
the ceiling as well as a stained glass
dome in the center with even more spider
imagery also worth mentioning is that
the room has no furniture of any kind
rather than a living space it looks more
like a room where some sort of ceremony
or ritual would have taken place in fact
it kind of reminds me of the boss
chamber from the forest temple all this
combined the underground setting wealth
of knowledge mysterious collection of
artifacts strange masks a ritualistic
room hidden inside a fireplace it all
has a lot of the characteristics of that
of a cult or some sort of secret
illuminati group it's also apparent that
the masks may have been involved in some
way there's a couple of them hanging on
the walls inside the main corridor as
well as the four distinct colored masks
next to the fireplace granted masks are
a central theme all over termina
especially in clock town but it's still
worth mentioning at least four chairs
four masks but what is by far the
strangest feature of the ocean house are
the paintings hanging on the wall of the
dining room as well as inside the
library which are depicting none other
than skull kid i don't think i have to
explain how incredibly weird this is i
mean what the heck are pictures of skull
kid doing inside a secret underground
mansion from termina's ancient past and
which has allegedly been hidden and
sealed off for who knows how long it is
confirmed that skull kid is incredibly
old he was there all the way back in the
time of the four giants and was even
friends with him when they left he felt
betrayed and neglected and as a result
the skull kid lashed out at everyone
around him causing trouble and mischief
all over termina so much in fact that
the people prayed to the giants to
intervene which they did awakening from
their slumber and threatening to kill
the imp if he refused to leave of course
one could make the argument that perhaps
skull kid himself once lived inside the
ocean house but i'm not really feeling
it on that one no offense to the
fictional woodland imp but he doesn't
exactly seem like the type that would
build an ornate underground mansion for
himself or study and read hundreds of
books collect ancient artifacts
specializing curses and hold secret
rituals skull kid is a creature of the
woods he might be a menace but he's not
some evil genius he's a playful
childlike being who like the kokiri is
blessed with immortality and his
encounter with majora was not something
he himself planned and happened purely
by accident however since skull kid did
cause a great deal of trouble back in
the day it is plausible that he is well
known around these parts even back in
ancient times of course that still
doesn't explain why anyone would have
multiple paintings of him hanging around
in their secret underground house one
option is that perhaps the people who
built the spider houses worshiped or
idolized skull kid in some weird twisted
way maybe they had a grudge or feelings
of betrayal towards the four giants or
the inhabitants of termina 2 and they
viewed skull kid as some sort of bringer
of chaos or something a bit like how the
yiga clan started worshiping ganon after
feeling betrayed by the king of hyrule
an alternative would be that some way
somehow these people knew that skull kid
would one day play a big role in the
destruction of termina by majora like
some sort of doomsday prophecy
predicting future events whatever the
case may be a lot of the evidence found
inside the houses does seem to point to
this having been a cult of some kind a
small handful of individuals who
operated in secret and had access to
hidden knowledge be it in the form of
the occult magic practices curses the
worship of false deities or some sort of
doomsday prophecy it's anyone's guess
really in fact who's to say that these
people didn't have good intentions
instead just because they were secretive
doesn't automatically mean that they
were evil for instance on the doors of
the ocean spider house we can find three
hylian characters which one put together
form the japanese word hirake meaning to
become opened up to improve to develop
or to be enlightened what this means
exactly for their motivations or
practices i'm not too sure after all
most cults usually think that they're
the good guys what's certain is that
whoever they were they haven't been
around for a long time so what could've
happened to them of course the
possibilities are many so let's cover
two options which i could at least find
some evidence for and in both cases the
original inhabitants never left and are
still inside option one is that they may
have accidentally fallen victim to their
own curse we do find a few regular
sculptulas inside the oceanside mansion
so maybe this is what remains of them
but in order for this to be true we have
to assume that given enough time the
curse will gradually deprive you of any
remaining human features and turn you
into a sculptola for good something
which we cannot prove unfortunately
there's also only three scotulas to be
found instead of four so either one went
missing or managed to escape the curse
or maybe even betrayed and cursed the
other three it's just a wild guess i
mean we don't even know for sure if
there were four individuals involved
that's all just based on the four chairs
and masks this leads to option two
inside one of the unfinished rooms of
the swamp spider house we can find a
massive stone monument and the game's
files confirm that it's supposed to be a
tomb if that's true then who or what is
buried here unfortunately i wasn't able
to translate the writing i searched
online and asked other people but
apparently the characters are too blurry
to make out what it says the only thing
that's almost certain is that it is
highly in writing so if any of you
watching want to take a crack at it be
my guest the fact remains that it's a
very peculiar location for a grave it
has its own unique design different from
other tombstones and monuments in the
game and serves no actual in-game
purpose you can't interact with it or
push it open or anything like that not
to mention it's pretty damn huge quite
the overkill if there's just one single
person buried here unless it's a giant
so could this be the final resting place
of this mysterious group or at the very
least one or more of its most prominent
members it could be that they realized
that their end was drawing near either
because of old age or some other factor
maybe they were found out who knows it
would at least explain why this spider
house was seemingly never finished maybe
they died before they had the chance
looking at it from this perspective it
also makes the implication of the curse
make a lot more sense maybe as the group
was about to close the curtains on the
whole thing they placed the spider's
curse onto their property as a final
measure a way to ensure that no one
could take possession of their wealth
and secrets after they were gone
whatever the case may be they will for
now remain one of termina's many
unsolved mysteries and there's very
little chance that this will change in
the future after all at the end of the
day it's just an insignificant location
disconnected from the main story a video
game level where you collect spiders and
solve puzzles to get a nice reward but
that's also what makes it fun to come up
with a story where essentially there is
none the less you know about a place the
more freedom you have to let your
imagination and creativity run wild
thank you for watching a shout out to
selamore for becoming my latest patreon
supporter and to francisco diaz for
becoming a member your support is always
greatly appreciated same goes for anyone
liking subscribing and watching my
content we are now only 2 000
subscribers removed from the big 100k
and when the time finally arrives i will
make sure to do something special again
and that is all for now this is dawn
signing off and have a good one
[Music]
you